we have so much to talk about and so
little time actually we have all the
time in the world it depends how much
time you want to spend here chatting
with me about the new iphone 14 the new
airpods pro 2 and of course the new
apple watches
let's just jump right into it and start
talking about the iphone 14 so there's
four new models of the iphone 14 we have
the iphone 14 the 14 plus the 14 pro and
the 14 pro max the 14 is a 6.1 inch and
the 14 plus is a 6.7 inch now both of
these are running the a15 bionic chip
which is the previous iphone 13 chip so
the only real upgrade with the chips is
in the iphone 14 pro models the 14 and
14 plus do have improved thermal
performance so obviously this will help
overall with the performance of your
phone there's five colors there's the
midnight star lights blue purple and
product red it has an xdr display that
goes to 1200 nits of brightness ceramic
shield front and of course we have our
12 megapixel camera which has an f 1.5
aperture and this gives us a 49
improvement in low light conditions i'm
excited they did update the front camera
so this now has autofocus they're using
this thing called the photonic engine
and this will now allow you to get way
more light in low light photos you'll
get up to 2x improvement on the front
and the ultra wide camera and two and a
half times on the main camera there's
also this new advanced action
stabilization so this is pretty cool
because i feel like a lot of times when
you're out filming and you want to get a
super steady shot you would have to use
a gimbal to be able to achieve some of
these shots some of the demos they
showed it was actually pretty impressive
so that's something that i can't wait to
try out now in typical apple fashion
they like to remove things well there's
now no more sim cards everything is
moving to esim on the iphone 14 series
they did show a little demo of how easy
it is to transfer everything over to
esim and almost all of the carriers will
be supporting that so that is happening
with all of the us models there's two
new big features the crash detection so
if you happen to be in a car accident
your iphone will be able to detect that
you were in a car crash and be able to
call for help which i think is such an
awesome feature and i'm really
well i won't be testing that out but i
am excited for how many lives that that
could potentially help save something
else on saving lives is the emergency
sos satellite feature this was so cool
to kind of watch the demo and i feel
like this is going to be something
really fun to kind of test out i have
been a huge fan of taking out satellite
phones when i go hiking and apple
developed this technology that basically
you're going to kind of just hold your
phone up and you'll be searching for the
satellite so your phone will detect
where the satellite is and you'll be
able to
basically beam yourself up they made
this really cool interface that if you
are in need of help and assistance being
able to send text messages can sometimes
take a lot of time because you are
sending it directly all the way up to
these satellites and it has to beam back
down and then get to the person and they
develop this way that they're able to
make those text messages even smaller in
size so they should be able to send
quicker they also have a really cool
interface that allows you to show what
type of emergency that you're having
select which one it is and then that
will help get you help quicker the
iphone 14 is starting at a 7.99 price
tag and the iphone 14 plus is at 8.99
now for our pro series which is always
my personal favorite we have the iphone
14 pro and the iphone 14 pro max it
comes in four colors we have this space
black silver gold and deep purple i mean
the deep purple is obviously one of my
favorite colors it looks so incredible
but i'm such a huge fan of gold as we
can see here so i'll probably order the
gold phone again i'm not sure i don't
know maybe i'll order the purple i just
don't know i haven't decided yet so the
iphone 14 and the 14 pro have one huge
difference that is the notch is still
prevalent on the iphone 14 and the
iphone 14 pro has this new pill shape
design now this is where i was so
shocked because apple had this thing
that they decided to call that pill
shape design not a pill shape not a
cutout they called it a dynamic island
and when they
said that like the crowd was like
laughing because it's such a random name
but it's the most perfect name because
it is exactly what it is is a floating
island that dynamically changes as you
open things on your phone it will change
to reflect whatever is open if you're
playing music if you have a timer
started you can then force hold on that
dynamic island to open it back up and
close it again so it's kind of like
another way to show and hide
notifications now this does have a pro
display it has a 1600 nit brightness
which is same as the pro display xtr but
at its peak brightness it goes up to 2
000 nits which is the maximum and that's
twice as bright as before we also now
have an always on display which i know
android
i get it i know you've had it before
well now we have it and we're all here
for it and we are very excited so please
don't rain on our parade we've managed
to survive this long without it so you
know we good so the new pro phones are
using the a16 bionic chip and of course
these are the fastest chips in a
smartphone to date now the six core cpu
which is 40 faster than the competition
and it also uses 20 less power than the
a15 the new pros have a new camera
system as well which is always so
exciting for me as a content creator i
love filming i love taking photos here
is our main camera this has a 48
megapixel camera with their new quad
pixel sensor this has the second gen
sensor shift optical image stabilization
with a 20 millimeter focal length in the
main lens now the main camera also has
two times better low light photo
capabilities and you can also use apple
pro raw the ultra wide camera has an f
2.2 aperture and it has three times
improvement for low light it's also got
a sharper lens which is way better for
macro shots there's also a new 2x
telephoto which is an f 1.78 this is
pretty interesting because it kind of
takes your main camera and your
telephoto and kind of merges them
together and gives you this new two
times shot so you'll have your 0.5 your
one two and your three they now have a
nine led adaptive flash this is pretty
cool because you have these varying
ranges of focal lengths and your zooms
this will allow the flash to
automatically adjust depending upon how
close you're shooting or how far away so
it's able to either be brighter or be a
little less bright depending upon your
subject and what lens you're shooting
with so the pros also can shoot in
prores video which is really great
especially if you're an editor and you
want to have more control over the color
also the action mode is coming to the
pros so you'll be able to get super
steady shots in situations which would
normally require a gimbal cinematic mode
was something that they launched last
year which i don't i don't really think
i've actually really used it very much
since last year i kind of forgot about
it and one of the reasons was because it
only shot 1080p but now you're able to
shoot in 4k so i think that's gonna kind
of change the game for a lot of people
who may have been a little hesitant to
use it before it's now 4k and you can
shoot 30 frames a second and 24. now
it's really cinematic the iphone 14 pro
is starting at 9.99 and the iphone 14
pro max is at 10.99 and storage options
range up to one terabyte next we have
apple watch series eight i am a huge
apple watch fan i've had one since the
very beginning and i'm so excited that
they now announced that it has a
temperature sensor and for anyone who
has a period this is very exciting
because being able to track that
is tedious sometimes it's not accurate
and being able to have that temperature
accuracy is really incredible for us
also for those who may be trying to get
pregnant or trying not to get pregnant
so with that temperature sensor being
able to track your ovulation track your
cycles i think this is going to be super
helpful for a lot of people the series 8
is swim proof dust proof and crack
resistant it also has the new crash
detection much like the new iphone
having the crash detection feature the
apple watch also now does have that
feature so if you are just wearing your
apple watch and you don't have your
phone crash detection will also be
available on the apple watch which again
hopefully something that i never need
but it is really great and kind of puts
my mind at ease knowing that i have
these devices in place if something does
happen series 8 has all-day battery life
and they do have this new low power mode
that will be able to optimize to get you
even more time they said that you should
be able to get up to 36 hours of battery
life when you're in that optimized mode
it comes in four different aluminum
colors we have the midnight the
starlight the silver and the red and
there's three colors of the steel we
have silver gold and graphite it'll be
3.99 for the gps and 4.99 for cellular
they also made some updates to the apple
watch se it comes in three colors silver
midnight and starlight it still has all
of the same safety features like the
emergency sos fall detection crash
detection it now has a 30 larger display
than the series 3. it has the same
package as the series 8 so it's now 20
faster than before this watch i feel
like is perfect for kids or family
members because you can use the family
setup so if someone doesn't have an
iphone you'll still be able to enable
this watch under the family setting this
brings us to the brand new apple watch
ultra now i think that we thought this
was going to be called the apple watch
pro there were rumors that it would have
an additional button it would be larger
this and that well here it is this is it
it's the apple watch ultra this is
definitely a very extreme edition of the
apple watch there's so many features on
here that i feel like a lot of people
will never ever use in their everyday
life this is definitely an adventure
watch this is for people who are going
out doing things you're super active i
am definitely a very active person but i
feel like this might even be a little
too much for me but is that going to
stop me absolutely not i definitely will
be getting the ultra to check out i do
love running i do love doing all sorts
of fitness activities and i do have also
very small wrists so when i first put
this watch on it definitely felt pretty
large but because it's made of titanium
and ceramic it didn't feel heavy it
really felt very similar to the size of
my other apple watch that i have now and
this is the smaller version so going
from this to the 49 millimeter was
pretty shocking just the touch of the
watch face because it's like a flat
design now it was really cool because it
kind of felt like you had a very mini
iphone on your wrist it's ultra durable
it has aerospace grade titanium the
display is a flat sapphire crystal it
has a larger digital crown and of course
this added action button that you can
customize to be whatever action you want
it to be when you click it it's got a
second speaker for increased volume it
has cellular built-in it'll get you up
to 36 hours of battery on a single
charge and you can get 60 hours of
battery life after a new optimization
that is coming later this fall it has a
night mode feature so when you twist the
dial it will turn red and all of the
blue light will disappear which will
help if you're out in the middle of the
night this red is so much easier on your
eyes it also has precision dual gps so
this will help with triangulating
exactly where you are and it'll have way
more precise gps especially if you're in
areas like you're running between
buildings or you're in various locations
where there may be some interference
sometimes the gps doesn't work that well
so hopefully this will solve that
problem now we also got a little treat
that was a little bit of a surprise i
mean yes the rumors sort of hinted that
there may be a possibility of some
airpods and we did indeed get some
airpods pro 2. now i got a chance to
test these out hands on i got to listen
to them and it was pretty incredible
especially because i still use the gen 1
air pods almost pretty much all the time
because i have such a weird ear shape
that sometimes they don't stay in my
ears even the new threes so still the
first gen is still my favorite so i was
glad to see that they have a new smaller
tip on the airpods pro two so hopefully
that'll help them stay a little bit
better in my ears but the sound quality
on the pros is so incredible especially
going from the gen ones that i'm so used
to listening to just the new adaptive
noise cancellation i'm excited to get my
hands on them or get my ears
on them i'm yeah so the design is very
similar to the previous pros but they do
have a brand new h2 chip like i said
they have the new extra small ear tip
they have the adaptive transparency mode
this will adjust safely for high decibel
noises i also tried this out at the
event it was cool because you could
actually look at your apple watch and
you could see the decibel sound changes
and saying that you were now in a safe
zone when i had the air pods in the
noise cancellation mode so that was kind
of cool to really see real time an
actual change happen they've got some
touch controls so when you squeeze the
little bottom of the air pod it will
actually switch from noise cancellation
and to off again you can also adjust the
volume by sliding up and down it's
pretty intuitive and i'm still pretty
impressed how great these sound they
also have a longer battery life so
you'll get about six hours of listening
time on a single charge which is 30
percent better and you'll get a total of
30 hours of listening time with the case
they added a speaker at the bottom of
the airpods now so when you use find my
air pods you'll be able to hear them way
better than before which is so smart
because i lose my air pods all the time
and i'm sure i'm not the only one i do
normally find them though they added a
little lanyard connector here so you'll
be able to connect a lanyard so not only
will be able to find your airpods
hopefully they'll still be connected to
you and you won't have to look very far
these also have personalized spatial
audio capabilities now this is not i
guess a new technology but it's
definitely new for apple sony's had this
for a while where you scan your ear and
it'll basically give you a personalized
spatial audio that will represent the
shape of your ear not really sure how
this all works but it is kind of
interesting and i know that it's cool
but sony has done that for a while and
now apple has decided to follow in their
footsteps and i can't wait to scan my
ear like i'm ready here we are let's do
it scan time so that my friends was kind
of a first look at everything that apple
announced at their event i'm definitely
excited about the new iphone obviously
that's kind of what i look forward to
every year so i'm looking forward to
checking that out but i am kind of
excited about the apple watch ultra now
i feel like i don't do that many intense
activities like most people who would
get this watch would i think the coolest
feature is they were talking about how
incredible this is for diving because as
soon as you would dive into the water it
would automatically detect and you'd be
able to detect the temperature of the
water how far you're diving and i think
that's just so cool and i think this
watch is really going to change the game
for a lot of people who do that type of
high active adventure activities so i'm
super excited to watch reviews of people
who really will push the limits of this
watch let me know if there's anything
specific that you would like me to test
out in any of these devices and if you
guys are new here hello hi i'm justine
and i am obsessed with tech and i'm a
huge iphone apple fan i have a bunch of
other videos that you may be interested
in so be sure to go check those out and
if you haven't already please subscribe
and hit the bell so you'll be notified
when i post new videos i look forward to
making a bunch of fun new videos it is
officially tax season and i will
definitely be making a bunch more videos
in the upcoming months so with that i
will see you guys in my next video bye
[Music]